[Musique]
vous entendez s'il y a bien une espèce
qui est à l'origine de ce projet fou
quel est le zoo de Beauval c'est bien
les oiseaux 1980 Françoise Delort
actrice de renom décide à d'ouvrir un
parc ornithologique 40 ans plus tard
c'est près de 600 oiseaux qui donnent un
spectacle grandiose ici dans cette
émission de 3000 places alors chouette
tourterelle hirondelle ce sera plutôt
des rapaces et des condors c'est un
petit peu plus gros
donc je vais rencontrer des rapaces et
des conteurs c'est parti alors
franchement on est bien ici tu
travailles quand même au Paradis
franchement je demande pas plus j'ai
entendu dire qu'il y avait une naissance
oui effectivement il y a une naissance
là en début de saison on a la chance de
s'occuper d'un couple de Condor et on a
eu la chance d'avoir un jeune mâle qui
est né il y a quelques mois qui est
encore pour le coup ni avec les parents
c'est arrivé que des oiseaux ou d'autres
espèces ont été réintroduits dans la
nature à partir d'ici oui ça arrivait
justement avec un condor des Andes qui a
été relâché pour le coup dans la nature
donc du coup qui allait rejoindre ses
congénères voilà en Argentine bah viens
avec moi du coup on va juste aller faire
l'entraînement des petits vautours et du
coup bah je t'invite à me suivre
[Musique]
on lui donne son petit morceau de viande
ils sont nés le visage comme ça là
franchement merci
de ce truc là
je pense que je suis prêt pour mon
premier cours de fauconnerie alors du
coup donne-moi du coup je vais te donner
un morceau de viande ton oiseau il
arrive il se pose sur ton gant au moment
où il arrive tu ouvres ta main il se
pose d'abord et j'ouvre la main c'est ça
allez bras bientôt
ça s'appelle un vent en direct les
femmes me mettent des vents mais les
oiseaux aussi ça ça franchement ça fait
mal peut-être il se rend pas compte il y
a de la jambe il y a de la viande il y a
de la viande vas-y lève ton bras
et voilà tu as envie et je suis vivant
tiens tu as le droit à un autre morceau
de viande merci quel effet ça se fait de
savoir le sûrement que ces animaux
magnifiques sont inscrits au patrimoine
de l'Unesco c'est un art on a toujours
utilisé les rapaces pour chasser et
c'est juste génial que ce soit classé à
ce niveau là quoi vas-y app et là tu
ouvres la main et tu le mets là haut
voilà tranquille voilà tu vois lui il
est devenu pote avec toi tu lui as donné
à manger du coup il t'aime bien yes mon
pote maîtriser son anxiété surtout ne
jamais montrer sa peur
voilà
est-ce que toi tu participes au
spectacle
alors que la partie rapace pour le coup
parce que c'est mon secteur on dit quoi
on dit tu es soigneux on dit tu es
dresseur les deux on dit quoi on est
soigneur soigneur on est soigneur
animalier la fauconnerie en fait de base
c'est un terme qui va être utilisé pour
la chasse la fauconnerie de chasse nous
là voilà on fait du spectacle on reste
des soigneurs tu peux venir viens
l'oiseau Michel Fugain c'est comme
l'oiseau
la vie nerfure et d'eau fraîche l'oiseau
mais jamais rien ne l'empêche l'oiseau
mais il n'y a rien de n'empêche l'oiseau
d'aller plus haut la vache ça marche
[Musique]